el tema de la escuela ha sido utilizado
como una forma de campaña inclinada sin
miedo del electorado un poco tratando de
poner el ejemplo de la crisis política
económica de venezuela a la hora de
persuadir al votante de que no se vaya
por la opción que estaba y que está de
hecho políticamente cercana al gobierno
social de los actuales del presidente
nicolás maduro en realidad también el
tema de la inmigración venezolana a
servir un poco para generar esta
preocupación en el electorado de hasta
qué punto ir por ciertas opciones
electorales y más específicamente el
caso de lan podría llegar a ecuador
progresivamente
estar en la misma situación de crisis
tanto económicas como políticas como
realizar anuncios a la hora
especialmente en el ámbito económico
porque como ustedes saben ecuador ejerce
ya varios años desde un país dolarizado
y en realidad lado la descripción ha
permitido que se puedan mantener los
niveles de vida aceptables que no exista
sobre todo la inflación la devaluación
de la moneda que ha captado el patricio
de contas entonces embargar el tema de
los que lo utilizó también el transfondo
del temor de la desdolarización y del
impacto económico que una bebida de este
tipo podría causar en el país entonces
creo yo que no tienen temores es de s la
consecuencia segunda plantearon en
algunos compañeros de electoral y de
desdolarizar económico que le no sería
convertirse en venezuela y transitar
hacia una crisis económica de iguales de
pensados y peores de muchos
ahora con respecto a la migración de
nuestra lana yo creo que muchas veces no
sólo en el contexto de esta de esta
campaña electoral se ha utilizado mal la
existencia y la confluencia de salidas
por ecuador un poco para atemorizar
también a la población en contra de los
migrantes venezolanos a quienes
desafortunadamente se activa tizado se
ha criminalizado pero que también siguen
siendo la prueba o el desprecio del que
existe una situación grave en del icio
la que no quisiéramos aplicar en otros
países